Oh Kevin it's lovely to have you here
that Cambridge film festival with how i
live now and what was the appeal of
adapting mcgraw scoffs novel for the big
screen I just really thought it was a
beautiful book and very unusual and I
think there's so many interesting things
going on in young adult fiction I think
it's more vibrant more experimental more
more interesting than what's going on in
adult fiction actually and I read it
just out of interest somebody gave it to
me said this is a great book and I read
and I thought this would make a
beautiful film and there's it's quite um
as a book it appealed to adults and two
and two teenagers and I wanted to make a
film that did both of those things as
well now of course saoirse ronan xin the
lead role daisy and that you're actually
originally looking for an unknown
American actors weren't you so how did
sir she come on boy then well yeah I am
I always saw this as being a very small
film with their stars I wanted it to be
unknown exactly my thought I'm gonna
find a lovely boy young boy in English
countryside somewhere he's going to play
the leading male role and I'm going to
get an unknown teenage American girl and
I spent with my casting director several
months in American looking for a teenage
girl who would be correct for and I met
love the famous actresses of young you
know been their teenage years and I met
literally hundreds and thousands of of
just you know non-professionals and it
couldn't find anybody alight and then
somebody said no of saoirse ronan you
know is interested in reading for it and
I don't really want so she could see
wonderful bird but I want an unknown is
it apart and then after about six months
of looking I thought my maybe I'll just
see if she's like and she came in and
she read and jedan prepared that the
lines even because because she hadn't
got the emails of a mix-up and she came
in she read them once and she's it and
she had us all in tears and she was so
wonderful I think what I've been doing
I've been wasting my time she said that
she's absolutely brilliant actor and
George is well George Michae you've got
in the male lead well how did he come on
board again it was similarly difficult
time I had the casting director or going
out to schools over all over written for
months and months and I think I'm I saw
a tape of
very early on and I thought well he's
too old because at that stage I thought
that the character playing days either
actress playing days it would be younger
and I thought oh he's too old but then
as it often happens you know once I men
cast one then he became appropriate and
actually i read i read Saoirse with five
boys and he was one of them and i
obviously part of it is that they have
to be attracted to each other and I
think he's finally theoretically of
interest and so it was obvious from the
reading between the two of them that you
know what everything works on screen
that you can definitely see that going
to between the two of them it's actually
quite a grown a troll compared to what
sir she stood in the past isn't it in
terms of its her first on-screen love
scene as well we've got in there is that
is that kind of responsibility than as a
director leading a young actress into
that kind of part and through that wrong
well I think you know she doesn't need
much guiding for me she's such a really
wonderful brilliantly talented actor but
it is a it is a different room people
have seen anything before I think she's
often played either children or kind of
as in Hannah you know she plays a child
who is a sort of feral creature but who
has a sort of a simplicity and agro
sense of grace to her was this character
is quite a prickly difficult teenager
trying to find their way and in life and
she's pretty tough so my one direction I
was always giving her all the way
through shooting was be tougher be more
of a [ __ ] be more of a [ __ ] go on
because she's naturally such a sweet
gentle person hey call me many directors
out there telling their lead actresses
be more a [ __ ] now it's a film that's
in a way of fill of two horses in two
quite distinct and how did you find
addressing that challenge as a director
cuz it means you've got lots of
different tones in there there's
something well what I what I set out to
do and I don't know if received it
audiences have two judges I wanted to
make a film where you think you're going
in one direction you think you're
watching one kind of film for the first
40 minutes and then it turns
dramatically into something else because
that was the experience for me reading
reading the
burg but also I wanted to play in a very
sort of filmic way with expectations of
genre so when you start the film it's
quite light and turn quite comedic even
and it feels like it fits into a kind of
you know familiar team film kind of
world of a difficult troubled girl who
comes thing this countryside and is
going to be in some way icky word by
love cured of her troubles and so you I
want to law they'll incentive sort of
false sense of security and then clip
the carpet under their feet that was
that was that was the idea and in terms
of the look as well you've got director
photography Franz listing on board this
time haven't you how was it working with
him and getting that feel in terms of
how them looked as well um he was one of
the I met him doing a commercial which I
very occasionally do and I was telling
him about this script I was developing I
wanted to do and he was so responded to
it he such as sort of he's German and
he's sort of a particular kind of German
hippie add column he's very sensitive
and nature loving and get combined with
some German efficiency which is very
useful in a caramel but he responded so
strongly to the world of the film and I
sent to read and and so I thought they
were he's the man and and I really
wanted somebody who was going to capture
a sense of the British countryside
because in some ways it's a film about
when I say about England we filmed it
mostly in Wales actually but it is sort
of about England and about English sense
of the folklore and and folk music and
they kind of the magic of the English
countryside and the English website
plays is a very strong part in it you're
filming something completely different
at the moment aren't you from how i live
now Black Sea with Jude Law how things
going well they were working well till
last week we were there last week of
principal photography and we had a
couple of weeks at the end in a tank
pinewood studios and we're filming
underwater sequences with three actors
walking across the seabed and various
things and
submarine film I should explain and we
put something into the tank but turned
all the water bright yellow haha on
Monday so we then put something another
chemical we needed a sort of a couple of
cambridge chemistry graduates because we
always didn't know what we were doing we
put something else into the water that
night that turned it green the next day
and then we added something else and it
became just a sort of milky soup so we
had to call off filming actually so
we're now i'm just waiting that is that
have organized again to finish the last
week of the film which is strange things
I've finished unexpectedly and now I'm
tenterhooks hoping the insurance money
comes through the challenges of filming
with water today and they say it's
things like children and animals that
cause problems everything is true but
what they say about water and of course
you've also got we've heard recently
signed on for and last train to Memphis
as well which is I'm very excited to
hear it Elvis Fanny you're a fan of
Elvis's music too I am a fan of Elvis
but I'm as much as that I'm I'm
fascinated to attempt to him it's very
early days haven't got a script yet that
we like and I haven't got an Elvis which
is probably even harder but in some ways
to deconstruct the the image the legend
and there was something I very much
enjoyed the film I made a couple years
ago called Marley about Bob Marley and I
tried to bring some of the sort of
investigative impulsive suppose that
came into that documentary into this
into this feature film and say it's
early days yes I was gonna say actually
about Marley because it seemed a kind of
nice interesting progression from the
documentary looking behind that Miss to
going behind the myth of Elvis i guess i
mean it's for the early years its base
isn't it well it would go up to when he
meets facility think or you've staying
quite quite early on in the sun years no
it's very early on it's sort of elvis
before he's Elvis I was I was becoming
Elvis I suppose it's it's kind of up
until the up until his last well sorry I
don't really know yet but I think it's
up until his his signing with RCA and
going with the colonel tom parker his
notorious famous manager and that really
is the last act of that act to the film
so it finishes in 1957 it's hard I guess
I mean you did it with Marley's oh wow
but it's hard to guess to go behind
these people who are so well known if I
have such an idea of what they're like
already how do you feel about that as
the director getting behind what
someone's really like and changing
people's maybe or giving different
perspective on them at least well it's
hard not to make a biopic that is a
cliche and that's what you want to avoid
and Elvis is obviously such a familiar
figure one of the most familiar figures
in the world but he's also a figure of
fun these days and so you have to
somehow really subvert expectations and
that's what I want stranding how do you
think it's gonna be the search for an
active scene as a young actors website
with world where people could upload
their Elvis auditions as it were well
that's again something is very open at
the moment we opened at the moment I you
can obviously go two ways you can go
with somebody who looks like Atlas which
I suspect it's probably not so good or
you can go to someone who's just a great
actor who's going to reveal something
truthful about who he was and if you
look down back at all at John
Carpenter's Elvis film with Kurt Russell
or was it early days for that yeah no I
have look to that and actually it's so
very entertaining I think it's funny
there's been several TV movies and was a
TV series in America a few years ago by
Elvis but there's never been a movie and
which is strange when has been movies
about almost everybody and I think one
of the reasons for that is that it's
it's so hard to grapple with the
mythology so yeah as I say it's early
days we're not we're not filming anytime
soon so hopefully I can find a way into
it I'm sure you will do and it's been
lovely talking to you Kevin really
enjoyed how i live now and good luck for
when that comes out in October thanks
you